una firma que pone fin a años de
enemistad el canciller de venezuela
carlos faría y el canciller designado de
colombia álvaro leyva acordaron
normalizar relaciones binacionales desde
el 7 de agosto
inspirados en la gesta histórica del
libertador simón bolívar han reafirmado
los lazos históricos de hermandad
complementariedad y cooperación que unen
a nuestros pueblos la reunión fue en
venezuela y el canciller local también
habló de esta nueva fase
hemos acordado él
establecimiento una vez que llegue es el
momento por supuesto
inmediato restablecer a los
embajadores que van a representar a
nuestros países tras su victoria en los
comicios de junio el presidente electo
de colombia gustavo petro se puso en
contacto de inmediato con el presidente
venezolano nicolás maduro
una apuesta diplomática contraria a la
de la administración precedente de iván
duque en 2019 rompieron relaciones
después de estas declaraciones quiero
expresar que colombia
reconoce a juan guaidó como presidente
de venezuela y acompaña este proceso de
transición hacia la democracia para que
el pueblo venezolano se libere de la
dictadura la normalización también
traerá la promesa de la reapertura de la
frontera de 2.219 kilómetros que
comparten ambos países está cerrada a
los vehículos desde 2015 desde entonces
el intercambio comercial se redujo un 70
por ciento